so many great holiday movies outright oh
that holiday movies and Andy I know
you've been spending a lot of time at
the theater yes I have Conan and it went
okay with you I'd like to share some
movie reviews with the crowd if that's
ok of course it's okay all right
that's amazing ladies and gentlemen it's
time now for Andy's holiday movie Guide
[Applause]
[Music]
ah boy I tell you with family in town
for the holidays a great way to find
time for yourself is going to the movies
and one of this season's best is Lady
Bird it's one hour and 34 minutes long
or approximately enough time for five or
six drinks and a competitive game of
pool with whoever's at the bar and if
anybody in your family asks I hear Lady
Bird dies to be yeah wait wait a minute
wait a minute Andy you didn't say much
about the actual movie next up is realm
and je Israel Esquire I here this one's
really good it's two hours and nine
minutes or approximately enough time to
meet your friend Manny at the bowling
alley in Glendale they have half off
shoes on Tuesday and the margaritas are
so good over there anyway I hear that
Denzel dies in the end of wait am i Andy
Andy you're not really reviewing the
movies you're just telling everybody how
long they are well like I said if you
need some time away from the family
movies are a great option I mean just
make sure you actually buy the ticket in
case your wife checks the receipts
moving on when it's your turn to watch
the kids
I highly recommend Coco it's playing at
that big theater right next to the
Staples Center it's approximately the
length of a Lakers game and if you buy
the kids three tubs of popcorn and some
Milk Duds they won't even notice you've
been in the bathroom the whole time -
Andy I think we get the point oh yeah I
forgot I think Coco dyes with you no no
Andy Andy that's not even true
well I'm Andy Ritcher and I'll see you
at the movies
[Applause]
anyway while it's popcorn what are you
gonna do
you